[Musique]
nous avons l'intention de construire ces sous-marins à
adélaïde en australie
un nouveau partenariat de défense trilatéral
connu sous le nom d'orcas
joshua
utiliser à des
fins d'intimidation et de coercition ap
eliot
[musique
] respecter la convention des nations unies
sur le droit de la mer
et
[musique]
étranger
après hong kong taiwan se tient de
plus en plus en première ligne de la
liberté et  démocratie, nous espérons certainement
que ce pays partageant les mêmes idées continuera
à travailler ensemble pour assurer la sécurité de taïwan,
ce qui est dans l'intérêt de la
paix et de la stabilité et de la
situation de vision
[Musique]
moment historique
pacific
mesose économique
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
étranger
[Musique]
mais nous ne cherchons pas à
le répéter, nous ne cherchons pas une nouvelle
guerre froide
ou un monde divisé
en blocs rigides
ou en différences
[Musique]
dans
étranger
[Musique]
[Mu  sic]
être
[Musique]